o lula só os seus bonitos a mais no
vídeo e hoje vou ensinar como fazer um
sábado luxo
ultimamente tem nada a fazer coisas um
pouco mais complicadas então se fazer um
projeto e gerenciamento mais simples que
toda a gente consegue fazer em casa
a única dificuldade é que ela já os
leves mas vocês podem sempre desmontar
coisas velhas e nos placas de circuito
vocês vão lá encontrar de certeza leds
podem não ser todos da mesma cor mas
funciona também
os leds em 2011 é maior e outro elemento
mais pequeno
agora maior é positivo eo mais pequeno e
negativo é que vocês têm resultados
positivos para um lado e os negativos
para o outro lado
eu vou utilizar estas pilhas aqui de
volta e mais grandes porque elas
encaixam perfeitamente lá dentro mas se
vocês não tiverem podem usar aquelas de
volta em maio pequenas que também serve
agora vocês têm que adaptar àquela parte
interna para que ela se encaixem da
mesma maneira
vou utilizar uma folha com tamanho atriz
branca
mas se vocês quiserem mudar a cor por
exemplo se você estiver em leds brancos
mas quiserem outra coisa só usar em uma
folha de comigo vocês querem por fora e
assim vai resolver o nosso problema
é um falso sinal do fim eu espero que
tenham gostado desse projeto aqui
bastante simples e vou tentar trazer
mais projectos desta equipe não é
preciso muita coisa para serem
realizados
se você tiver alguma sugestão de algum
projeto é só deixar nos comentários
é isso muito obrigado investido até a
próxima